c'est parti pour un nouveau stream
consacré aux sciences sociales je vous
salue je vous dis bien le bonsoir
bienvenue sur la société ecc alors
aujourd'hui bien c'est dimanche et vous
savez que dimanche je vais en découvrent
ensemble un article de sciences sociales
plus ou moins récents ça dépend parce
que parfois il ya des thèmes qui sont
plus ancien mais qui sont super
intéressant en tout cas j'ai des
demandes n'oubliez pas aussi que voilà
s'il ya des thèmes qui vous intéressent
un peu plus mais a dit le mois de telle
sorte à ce que je prévois une
programmation en adéquation avec vos
attentes alors cette semaine bien voilà
c'est un article qui fait plaisir parce
qu'on va parler bien de pierre bourdieu
c'est finalement sa théorie qui va être
testé sa théorie des goûts un dégoût qui
seraient liées à notre position sociale
donc c'est quelque chose qui intéresse
beaucoup en tout cas sur la chaîne
youtube vous êtes nombreux à suivre ces
vidéos où je résume finalement la
distinction et je vois que sur youtube
en général quand il ya des travaux de
vulgarisation de pierre bourdieu il ya
quand même une grosse audience et une
grosse attente donc moi aussi je suis un
grand fan de bourdieu je trouve ça très
intéressant d'un point de vue de
découverte mais aussi pour sa propre vie
même si faire de l'auto n'a analyse
c'est pas toujours conseillé et donc on
va voir ça aujourd'hui je vous parle
aussi avant de commencer des prochains
rendez-vous vous savez que le mercredi
et le jeudi on se retrouve sur twitch
pour discuter des élections
présidentielles françaises voilà il nous
reste grosso modo trois semaines avant
c'est ce premier tour donc ça fait
plaisir on se retrouvent le mercredi
pour découvrir le programme d'un
candidat ou d'une candidate et le jeudi
pour en discuter et pour discuter de
différentes choses différentes m
voilà quoi ça vous pouvez retrouver les
informations sur le compte twitter de la
société alors la semaine prochaine les
choix sont déjà proposés 1 vous pouvez
voter dès la fin de ce stream sur la
chaîne youtube pour choisir finalement
l'article qui sera abordée la semaine
prochaine je vais vous donner les
différents choix
alors le millet choix ça va être tendu
je n'y suis pas encore voilà prévu les
parcours et scolarisation de trois
élèves à haut potentiel voilà bon c'est
c'est un thème qui est de plus en plus
abordé les trajectoires des hauts
potentiels nous dans l'enseignement on
est souvent confronté maintenant à des
élèves qui le ceux qui sont
diagnostiqués soit au potentiel soit
élève avec un trouble de l'apprentissage
et donc c'est un petit peu intéressant
de voir s'il ya des difficultés chez ses
élèves ou pas parce que souvent on va
relever les élèves qui ont des
difficultés mais j'avais lu un
spécialiste de la question qui disait
que
80% des des hauts potentiels
vivez une scolarité tout à fait
satisfaisante si pas plus
deuxième article j'espère franchement
que vous allez le choisir parce que je
laime beaucoup pulvérisation
démocratique où les clivages façon
puzzle donc déjà l'attitude est assez
sympa parce que moi j'adore ce vieux
film quel est ton flingueurs l'orgie les
vieux films parce que je sais que voilà
sur twitch le public est plutôt jeune
moi je suis déjà un vieux croûton sur
twitch mais voilà c'est ça m'intéresse
beaucoup ce thème est ce que le clivage
gauche droite a encore de la pertinence
est ce que les clivages socio économique
encore de la pertinence d'un point de
vue politique voilà si c'était si
c'était moi j'ai choisi la suis là et
puis un dernier thème un peu plus social
les inégalités sociales disposition et
usages du numérique comment est ce qu'il
ya des inégalités sociales par rapport
au numérique alors sur la chaîne youtube
vous retrouver dans l'onglet communauté
ce sondage ce choix que vous pouvez
opérer et alors je vous mets aussi les
résumés de chaque article comme ça vous
pouvez vraiment choisir en connaissance
de cause et vous ne pourrez pas vous
plaindre si ça ne vous convient pas
voilà tout ça c'est dit alors on va pas
perdre plus de temps et on va passer
directement à la lecture de cet article
je vais changer juste la fenêtre si vous
permettez alors je gère de mieux en
mieux obs studio je trouve que c'est un
outil assez formidable
s'il ya des choses que je ne fais pas
bien où des choses voilà où vous dites
ah tiens il pourrait faire un peu mieux
parce que vous êtes très souvent sur sur
twitch n'hésitez pas à me le dire
évidemment le chat est là pour vous
j'espère qu'aujourd'hui il y aura de
l'activité sur celui ci alors oui aussi
petite remarque la chaîne switch se
développe mais vous savez que plus on a
de visibilité plus on a des avantages
plus il ya des des potentialités des
paramètres qui s'ouvre pour moi j'irai
cette chaîne donc si vous n'êtes pas
encore follower alesi follow et c'est
totalement gratuit ça va me permettre
vraiment d'atteindre ce seuil de 50
follower qui permet après d'avoir des
nouvelles fonctionnalités donc ça c'est
dit aussi allez on y va fenêtres de
travail voilà vous retrouver ce fameux
article qui est disponible sur kairn
vous savez que kern c'est le grand
portail où plusieurs maisons d'édition
d'articles de sciences sociales vont
mettre à disposition gratuitement ou pas
certains articles alors tous les
articles qui ont plus de trois ans sont
gratuits je pense que ça c'est la
politique est peut-être des exceptions
mais globalement c'est comme ça et si
voilà l'article est payant pour vous
malheureusement je peux pas vous le
fournir parce que là je contreviendrait
aux droits d'auteur mais si vous faites
partie d'une faculté ou si comme moi
vous êtes lecteur d'une bibliothèque
universitaire ça ne coûte pas très cher
de s'inscrire pour une bibliothèque
universitaire ce n'est pas universitaire
et bien vous avez accès à l'ensemble des
revues il ya plus de 500 revue qui sont
mises à disposition et je vous dis aussi
que iliad est parfois des ouvrages même
super intéressant qui sont en
consultation complète de sapho va
vachement le coup d'activer ces codes si
vous êtes étudiant dans une université
ou dans une haute école mais si vous
n'êtes pas dans ce cas-là aller dans une
bibliothèque universitaire d'une
université demander une carte de lait
qu'une carte de lecteur contacté le
service informatique et vous aurez accès
à tous ces articles plus passionnants
les uns que les autres alors je pense
qu'une fois on va faire vraiment on va
aller sur kairn ensemble pour voir
toutes ses potentialités et tout ce
qu'il ya moyen d'aller dénicher sur
cette plateforme voilà moi je suis un
grand fan pour l'instant de cairns c'est
sans doute le site que je consulte le
plus bon voilà on va pas on n'est pas là
pour parler de ma vie alors on est sur
un antique de julien boyajian
boyadjian je ne sais pas comment ça se
prononce exactement
qui travaille notamment sur si j'ai bien
suivi ce qu'il fait sur aussi tout ce
qui est communication et aussi sur des
réseaux sociaux sur les réseaux sociaux
donc c'est assez intéressant parce qu'on
en reparlera j'ai vu des articles
récents qu'il avait publiés sur twitter
sur facebook si je ne me trompe pas et
donc ça peut être intéressant mais ici
voilà il s'attaque aux capitales
culturelles alors vous savez que le
capital culturel c'est un des concepts
formulée par pierre bourdieu pour rendre
compte finalement de notre disposition
personnel ou collectif
alors d'abord en matière de goût mais
après son travail va être évidemment
beaucoup plus plus plus large si vous
n'êtes pas un coutumier ou si vous
n'êtes pas une habituée du vocabulaire
de pierre bourdieu je vous conseille
fortement
avant de suivre ce stream ou alors vous
suivez ce stream de manière un peu cool
et là y'a pas de soucis mais si vous
voulez ne rien perdre de toutes les
subtilités de ce qu'on va dire
aujourd'hui où de ce que je vais essayer
de dire aujourd'hui eh bien il sur la
chaîne youtube la société que vous
retrouvez toute une série de vidéos qui
va vous parler de tous les concepts de
base qui vous permettent de comprendre
ce terme de capitale culturelle alors il
ya une vidéo qui vous parle notamment de
ses différents capitaux et puis il ya
une vidéo qui va vous deux vidéos que
vous vous parlez de commencer capitaux
joue pour déboucher sur des dispositions
durable tels que sont les habitus de
classe alors je vais quand même en dire
quelques mots parce que sinon je ferai
pas bien cet exercice de vulgarisation
de cet article le capital culturel en
fait c'est tout toute la matière que tu
peux avoir acquis au cours de ta
socialisation ça peut être du capital
culturel intériorisé un des dispositions
en terme de langage en termes d'attitude
en termes de connaissance
à côté de ce capital culturel
intériorisé tu as du capital culturel
institutionnalisée institutionnalisée
oui si je ne dis pas de bêtises ou du
capital culturel objective et donc ça
c'est par exemple des livres ou des
objets qui vont représenter un capital
culturel ça c'est là le grand apport de
la sociologie de pierre bourdieu c'est
d'amener tout cet aspect
culturelles aux ressources puisque avant
on considérait surtout les ressources
comme des ressources économiques et donc
sa cape et produit en parle avec le
capital économique mais bourdieu amène
cette dimension vraiment immatériel dans
le jeu en plus du capital social qui est
là plutôt un capital fait de
deux liens sociaux et de connaissances
que tu pourras avoir avec d'autres
personnes donc ça c'est pour te résumer
assez
rapidement et succinctement ce terme de
capitale culturelle et pour pierre
bourdieu bien en fait en fonction des
capitaux dont on va avoir par héritage
ou par acquisition personnel on va se
positionner différemment dans la vie on
va se positionner alors positionné déjà
avec le corps mais aussi avec nos
jugements avec nos comportements tout ça
va être différent en fonction du capital
que l'on dispose à la fois du volume de
capital donc la quantité de capital
tout capitaux confondues que ce soit du
capital économique de capitaux culturel
du capital culturel mais aussi en termes
de structure parce qu'il y aura des gens
qui ont beaucoup de capital mais des
gens qui ont dans cette classe aisée en
capital il y en a qui auront beaucoup de
capitales culturelles et un peu moins de
capital économique et d'autres qui ont
hao par exemple plus de capital
économique que de capitaux culturel donc
voila un petit peu pour te résumer
l'histoire est bon si tu veux cette
théorie là était fortement discuté
débattu depuis qu'elle a été mise
depuis qu'elle a été on dira publiées et
communiquer au public donc ça fait 40
ans qu'on se bagarre sur sur ce modèle
théorique est ici ben voilà on a un
article qui va nous nous proposer une
actualisation et de voir tout va dans le
titre un peu percutants est-ce que ce
capital structure culturelle structure
toujours les goûts et en particulier les
goûts des jeunes de 18 à 20 ans en
matière de cinéma donc je trouve ça
vraiment un bon choix car a été fait par
la communauté parce que tu vois la
question est posée sans ambiguïté c'est
facile à comprendre même si tu connais
pas bourdieu à fond dans la théorie de
bourdieu de fond en comble et surtout
ben voilà
18 20 ans est un petit peu aussi la la
catégorie d'âge qui est présente sur
twitter donc je trouvais ça intéressant
parce qu'on va parler finalement 2-2
vous quoi de vous les jeunes si vous
êtes jeune pour peut-être qu'il ya des
moins jeunes évidemment ils sont les
bienvenus aussi
allez on y va donc il ya toujours
l'abstract mais comme ils sont publiés
je bougeais pas le relire ce que je dis
souvent quand tu fais une recherche et
que tu tombe sur un article scientifique
line abstract parce que ça va
directement te donner tous les éléments
en fait c'est vraiment c'est l'auteur
qui résume lui-même l'article et ça m'a
donné vraiment tous les éléments
importants qui sont dans l'article et
donc si tu te rends compte que l'abe
star l'abstract ne répond pas à tes
questions que toi tu te poses
s'il n'y a pas d'information dans
l'abstract qui répondent à la question
de départ ben ne lit pas l'article parce
que tu nous on trouvera pas beaucoup
plus quelque part alors évidemment c'est
un peu plus compliqué que ça parce que
tu peux avoir des choses des passages
qui sont cités et qui t'intéresse mais
franchement quand tu es en début de
recherche bastoi sur cette abstract
après plus loin de ta recherche c'est
peut-être moi nécessairement début c'est
intéressant alors comme toujours j'ai
souligné ce qui me semblait moi le plus
important pour comprendre
l'ensemble de l'article évidemment il
faudrait tout lire si ça t'intéresse
l'itu moi j'ai pas la science infuse non
plus je suis pas en mesure de tracy tuer
je sais pas moi qui fais la recherche
nous voilà il ya des subtilités sans
doute que je vais
oublier que je vais je vais que j'ai
relevé déjà donc si tu veux vraiment
avoir toute la profondeur de l'article
vasily toucoing évidemment moi je fais
ici qu une vulgarisation pour montrer au
grand public
ce qu'est ce que sont les sciences
sociales est ici la sociologie en
particulier quoi ou est-ce que j'ai pas
dit ça vient de la revue sociologie qui
est vraiment une revue comme son nom
l'indiqué de sociologie et non pas de
sciences sociales ce qui est intéressant
avec cette revue c'est qu'il n'y a pas
de chapelle dans le sens où parfois tu
as des revues comme l'acte de la
recherche en sciences sociales ça c'est
la revue des bourdieusien donc si tu vas
là dedans tu vas trouver toutes les
théories qui tourne autour du travaux de
pierre bourdieu ici en sociologie tu va
peut-être avoir des travaux de ses
détracteurs par rapport aussi à des
travaux de gens qui vont plutôt
travailler dans le sens de sa théorie si
tu veux donc c'est une revue pluraliste
au point de vue des sciences sociales
vous avez peut-être vous dire mais c'est
quoi cette revue de sciences c'est quoi
c'est cette science les sciences
sociales où les gens sont pas forcément
d'accord alors moi personnellement je
trouve ça très simple qui est des des
combats des oppositions entre différents
auteurs et je vais vous le dire
franchement alors c'est pas consensuelle
de dire ça je pense mais moi j'insiste à
ces débats là en tant que prof du
secondaire et je regarde ça un petit peu
parfois comme comme un match de foot je
dis franchement j'aime bien aller voir
les arguments des uns les arguments des
autres ou comme un débat politique si
vous l'avez pour moi c'est c'est aussi à
auby en fait de regarder ça vous allez
me dire drôle de hobby mais je trouve
que ces oppositions sont parfois voilà
moi c'est intéressant j'aime bien j'aime
bien le débat j'aime bien les changes et
donc ça m'intéresse alors je regardais
dans la bibliographie parce que vous
allez voir c'est certes article 6 qui va
surtout être contestée par l'article
qu'on lit ici en fait en 2018 tu as eu
ben tu vois structure et historicité des
goûts musicaux et cinématographiques
analyse factorielle et interprétations
sociologique est en fait dans cet
article on va un petit peu attaqué la
théorie de bourdy en disant qu'elle
n'est pas opérante qu'elle ne fonctionne
pas et donc l'article qu'on lit
aujourd'hui va un petit peu prendre la
défense de la théorie de bourdieu par
rapport à cet article un peu accusateurs
alors voilà je suis en train de monter
un débat un match de rien du tout
évidemment c'est pas c'est plus simple
que simplement attaqué tous âges utilise
des termes un peu guerrier
parce que ça m'amuse beaucoup mais voilà
après ces échanges scientifiques
mais on va voir tout ça bon allez au
c'est parti on y va
la grande question de ce de cet article
c'est de savoir si l'affirmation d'une
homologie structurel entre l'espace
social les espaces de style de vie qui
est la clé de voûte de la distinction de
pierre bourdieu qui est vraiment le la
théorie intéressante par rapport
aux comment dire au goût qui seraient
liés à des positions sociales est sans
doute une des théories les plus discutés
dans le champ des sciences sociales ces
trente dernières années donc directement
ici l'auteur
je vais essayer de retenir son nom
boyajian ou boad gyan boyadjian julien
boyadjian
et bien directement pause l'intérêt de
son article c'est à dire qu'on va
essayer de trancher ou en tout cas
d'apporter peut-être pas tranché de
manière globale mais sur un objet très
délimiter un le cinéma des 18-29 ans les
goûts cinématographiques des 18 20 ans
on va essayer de trancher est ce qui
encore cette homologie structurale entre
l'espace social l'espace des styles de
vie alors tu peux te dire là déjà
qu'est ce que c'est que cette histoire
on commence déjà avec les mots
compliqués mais en fait il n'y a rien de
trop compliqué derrière ces mots là
l'homologie c'est le fait que tu as deux
espaces tu à l'espace social donc les
gens voient là ont des positions
sociales avec les classes populaires
avec les bourgeois lé la classe
dominante propres le vocabulaire de
bourdieu la classe moyenne est en fait
tu rends compte tu te rends compte qu'il
ya une structure et que quand après tu
prends les styles de vie des gens
indépendamment de leur classe sociale tu
vas voir que les gens par exemple qui
boivent de la bière c'est aussi ce qui
regarde du foot à la télé c'est aussi ce
qu'ils vont avoir des des répartition
des tâches ménagères très genre et tu
vois il ya une sorte de cohérence comme
ça qui va se dégager dans l'espace des
styles de vie et tu constates qu'en fait
quand tu remets ça entre quand tu
superposent ça à l'espace social et bien
tu as une même structure les classes
populaires sont à la fois celle qui aime
bien boire de la bière et qui regardent
le match de foot et qui en même temps
une commande est une division des tâches
ménagères très genre et tu vois ces
salles homologie c'est que l'espace
social correspond au style de vie à
chaque classe sociale correspond un
style de vie alors j'entends déjà
certains parce que voilà c'est un peu
politiquement pas correct la sociologie
quelque part dans le monde a dit
réaliste dans lequel on est où
finalement chacun vit selon sa propre
nature et tout ça bla bla bla bla bla
bla mais en fait oui tu peux avoir des
exceptions il faut pas faire l'imbécile
de service qui va arriver oui mais moi
je connais quelqu'un qui s'est pas comme
ça oui ok d'accord mais la sociologie
elle s'intéresse aux forêts elle
s'intéresse pas aux arbres isolés c'est
pas parce que tu as un arbre dans son
jardin qu' il n'y a pas une forêt plus
loin qui va avoir des caractéristiques
plus globale si tu veux
je prends un exemple souvent aussi du
poisson volant il ya des poissons
volants mais ce n'est pas l'essentiel de
l'espèce donc si tu dois bien comprendre
c'est qu'ici on ne s'intéresse pas aux
individus en tant que tel on s'intéresse
aux collectivités d'individus et c'est
le nombre qui fait les réalités
sociologiques finalement tu as toujours
un individu qui va pas rentrer dans le
modèle on pourrait dire que c'est
l'exception qui confirme la règle je ne
peux pas trop dire ça mais c'est que
peut-être que lui il a des facteurs
particuliers qui font que à une
trajectoire particulière qui fait que et
il faudrait vraiment rentrer dans le
détail de sa vie pour montrer que lui
aussi est un peu déterminé socialement
c'est le travail d'ailleurs de bernard
lahire alors je dis ça sous le contrôle
de ce qu'on lui bernard lahire parce que
je n'ai pas encore lu ça va pas traîner
le problème c'est qu'on sait pas tout
lire et beaucoup de lecture à faire mais
bernard lahire voilà c'est un petit peu
son travail si tu veux
donc c'est ça qu'on va voir parce que tu
vois comme j'ai souligné ici on va
souvent dire que ces dates et bourdieu
est d'ailleurs sur la chaîne youtube sur
toutes les vidéos de bourdieu j'ai
toujours des gens qui viennent commenté
en disant oui mais bon on prend
l'exemple du rap machin
part c'est un peu c'est un peu pénible
parce qu'en fait
beaucoup de gens croient que sur youtube
tu fais une vidéo de 5 minutes et que
grâce à cette vidéo de 5 minutes tu as
tout dit quoi non moi j'ai fait une
vidéo de cinq minutes qui parle du
travail travail de pierre bourdieu en
dans les années 80 afin en 1979 est donc
évidemment que ça a évalué évolué mais
bon ma vidéo n'était pas forcément sur
l'évolution de la théorie parce que
pierre bourdieu prévoit qu'il ya des
évolutions qui a des dynamiques qui sont
en marche et que évidemment ce qu'il dit
pour 1979 c'était valable en 79 mais
qu'après il ya eu des évolutions qu'il
avait notamment prévu donc voilà le
caractère date est bof bof et on peut
aller plus loin voire inopérant et là
c'est le fameux article de glevarec et
si bois qui va contredire
la théorie de pierre bourdieu alors ce
qui est intéressant si vous voulez enfin
ce qui est intéressant ce qui est
interpellant pour vous qui allez lire
des articles de sciences sociales ou
qu'il disait ou qui avait lu des
articles scientifiques
mais j'ai envie de dire c'est valable
pour tous les domaines de connaissances
que vous allez aborder alors en fait je
me suis rendu compte que j'ai déjà lu
ces articles celui ci est celui de
glaire varech et si moi je les ai déjà
lu et en fait quand je les ai choisis si
vous voulez faire quand j'ai choisi cet
article si pour le soumettre à la
communauté
eh bien je me souvenais plus de ce à
quoi et donc c'est pour te dire que
parfois tu peut même lire des trucs
voilà et puis tu te souviens plus tu les
as l'uqo et c'est seulement quand tu
rentres à nouveau dans les articles que
tu te souviens que de les avoir déjà
abordé et si vous faites des recherches
sur tout
ça peut vous apparaître comment dire
fastidieux embêtant lourd de faire des
mini résumé ou de prendre des notes pour
chaque article plutôt que les souligné
ainsi mais je pense enfin si c'est un
belgicismes pour dire comme ça mais je
pense que c'est ultra nécessaire voilà
moi j'ai pas fait de doctorat mais quand
je suis des podcasts de doctorants c'est
super important de prendre des notes
d'ailleurs si ça vous intéresse je vous
conseille un podcast journal d'une
doctorante c'est vraiment très
intéressant par rapport à la démarche de
recherche d'une thèse est donc prendre
des notes c'est essentiel pour pouvoir
les relire rapidement et pour se dire
oui tel article j'hallucine ont comme
moi vous avez oublié bon moi dans mon
cas c'est pas grave parce que je lis ça
pour ne pas dire pour passer le temps
mais voilà c'est pas j'ai pas un ange et
professionnelle derrière c'est juste
pour animer cette chaîne et pour ma
propre
érudition je le dirai comme ça voilà
doxa ce directement ce qui est
intéressante à la problématique qui est
proposé c'est d'une actualisation de
cette grande théorie de la distinction
et on te balance directement ici dans la
revue de la littérature dans ce qu'on
appelle l'état de l'art donc dans un
article scientifique tu vas toujours
avoir une première partie où l'auteur va
un petit peu regardez tout ce qui a été
publié sur la question donc ça c'est
essentiel sinon tu rates le côté comment
dire cumulatif de la science le fait que
c'est en se basant sur des travaux
précédente qui va pouvoir faire avancer
la connaissance et on reprend souvent la
métaphore de robert merton cessantes
mettant sur les épaules des géants qui
t'ont précédé que toi tu pourras voir
plus loin que eux quoi mais c'est
uniquement parce que tu montes sur leurs
épaules et donc c'est super essentiel de
faire le point et dès qu'on parle de
réactualisation des travaux de bourdieu
tu vas tomber sur cet auteur petersen
qui va te proposer des concepts donc il
a travaillé sur les genres musicaux
populaires aux états unis et en fait il
se rend compte que
il ya des genres légitime alors ça c'est
dans la théorie de bourdieu les classes
plus aisées vont allez sur les savoirs
ou les connaissances ou les
consommations culturelles les plus
poussées les plus les plus légitimes
celles qui ont de la valeur si tu veux
quelque part tandis que les choses comme
par exemple touche pas à mon poste mais
voilà ça va être plutôt consommer enfin
c'est un anachronisme puisqu'ils avaient
pas touche pas à mon poste du temps de
bourdieu mais c'est pour que tu
comprennes ben voilà du temps de
beaulieu c'était surtout les classes
populaires qui consommaient ce genre de
contenu tandis qu'aujourd'hui peterson
dans les goûts musicaux constate que les
classes aisées pourrait aller vers des
consommations style touche pas à mon
poste si tu veux un petit peu comme on
dirait s'encanailler est donc en effet
elles vont consommer des biens du
culturel légitime à l'opéra aller au
musée des trucs qui te vois sont sont
connotés avec beaucoup de valeurs
mais vont aussi aller sur des
consommations beaucoup plus populaire
est beaucoup moins légitime et donc on
va dire que les élites en tout cas les
élites américaines selon peterson sont
omnivores c'est à dire qu'elles vont
consommer de tous elle mange de tout
point de vue culturel tandis que les
classes moyennes et les classes
populaires elle elle reste sur des
consommations ben voilà qui sont
vulgaires entre guillemets et donc elles
vont être univoque et donc là il ya un
décalage par rapport à ce qu'a dit
bourdieu alors peterson je n'ai pas lu
en détail enfin en tout cas il pas
récemment mais à manger un grand défense
je vous le dis franchement j'ai un grand
défenseur de bourdieu parce que je passe
beaucoup de temps dans la distinction
aller à lire et relire pour essayer de
comprendre certaines choses et ici j'ai
recommencé enfin j'ai commencé à lire
microcosme qui est un bouquin qui vient
d'être édité avec des travaux de
bourdieu qui avait pas encore été édité
avec d un travail de reconstitution
aussi donc voilà je suis un peu un
bourdieusien si on peut dire ça comme ça
en toute modestie et ici on peut se
revendiquer de enfin le dire comme ça
donc moi je trouve que bourdieu l'avait
dit quoi en fait c'est pas tellement les
contenus chez bourdieu qui sont
essentiels c'est la relation d'ailleurs
j'ai fait un post sur un stade
aujourd'hui qui dit là qui fait le point
là dessus c'est si tu veux le
positionnement de 2 de chaque
consommation par rapport à celles des
autres qui est significative et pas le
contenu de la consommation en tant que
tel donc ici alors encore une fois j'ai
pas lu les travaux de peterson récemment
je pense que je les ai lu il ya une
petite dizaine d'années mais c'est plus
très frais faudrait j'y retourne
bon dieu disent ça dépend de la manière
dont tu va consommer les choses quoi
parce que voilà tu peux regarder tes pmp
je vous donne un exemple mon épouse on
regarde comment s'appelle cette émission
où il ya des crèches des choses comme ça
dit célibataire ou il ya 17 dit
célibataire dix hommes et dix femmes et
puis il ya des mix qui sont faire ils
doivent trouver leur crush ou quelque
chose comme ça je ne sais plus le nom de
cette émission enfin pour moi je trouve
ça vraiment une émission débile du
désolé si vous regardez bien voilà c'est
bon c'est mon avis mais ma femme regarde
mais quand elle regarde voilà elle va
toujours après être trouvée
d'interprétation géologique du truc de
qu'elle regarde pas au premier degré et
peut-être que si elle était d'une autre
catégorie sociale d'une autre classe
sociale peut-être qu'à regarder au
premier degré donc il faut aussi à mon
avis analyser la manière dont les gens
se positionnent par rapport au contenu
et c'est pas simplement le fait de
regarder
voilà donc pour moi ce cette typologie
omnivore unis vor et peut-être un peu
réductrice je dis bien peut-être un peu
réductrice des travaux de bourdieu me
semble-t-il me semble-t-il
mais voilà je encore une fois juste très
modeste par rapport à tout ça j'ai
essayé d'animer cette chaîne en toute
modestie je suis qu'un prof de
secondaire voilà j'ai pas passé et dans
le monde tant sur tout ça donc peut-être
que je dis des bêtises je vous dis bien
c'est mon avis avec mes connaissances
actuelles du jour peut-être que je vous
dire autre chose dans quelques temps
alors le second élément de discussion du
modèle théorique de légitimité
culturelle concerne la nature des
facteurs sociologiques structurant les
goûts 1 dans la distinction les goûts
qui sont générés par cet habitus
l'habitus c'est finalement notre façon
notre logiciel jamais utilisé ce mot de
logiciels d'algorithmes personnel qui
nous fait nous comporter d'une certaine
manière parce qu'on a intériorisé
certaines conduites du fed et des
capitaux qu'on a rapidement si je peux
donner un exemple par exemple tu n'as
pas beaucoup d'argent mais tu vas
toujours compté et tu vas être très
prudent dans tes achats quelque part tu
vois mais par contre d'un autre côté
comme t'as pas beaucoup d'argent ça ça
rien ont pu économiser parce que tu
arriveras jamais de toute façon
d'acheter une maison et donc tu vas
parfois avoir des dépenses qui peuvent
apparaître futiles comme par exemple
fumée ou aller boire des dépôts au
bistrot avec tes potes et pas si tu veux
calculé pour pour le lendemain donc tu
peux avoir quelque part une disposition
tu vois à calculer quand les les achats
sont sont très importants et très
onéreux et en même temps un petit peu de
dépenses et donc ça peut paraître
contradictoire mais en fait ça va te ça
va se créer une façon de voir les choses
c'est de voir le monde donc par exemple
quand tu veux avoir un ordi à 1000
balles tue à dire non c'est pas possible
un ordi à 1000 balles comment on peut
s'acheter un ordi à 1000 balles mais
d'un autre côté tu vas peut-être claqué
50 balocka au café quoi tu vas au
bistrot
et donc tu vas avoir toujours un rapport
comme ça l'argent assez particulier
d'amour haine j'extrapole à un peu à ce
que du bon dieu c'est pas exactement ça
mais c'est pour vous puissiez comprendre
et bien ça ça serait ton habitude si tu
veux ce rapport de dépenses et des
petites sommes mais de ne pas pouvoir
dépenser des grandes sommes et
finalement d'avoir une méfiance par
rapport aux grosses dépenses tu vois ça
serait ça serait par exemple un habitus
mais en fait un habitus ça va être
autant d en dire le logiciel qui te fait
te comporter d'une certaine manière que
ce que tu juges c'est les deux choses tu
veux
et donc les gauches générés par a b que
tu sont structurées en fonction de la
position occupée par les agents dans
l'espace social puisque c'est tes
capitaux qui vont surtout déterminée ton
habitude et ici on constate dans
certaines études que c'est plutôt l'âge
et que aujourd'hui l'âge serait plutôt
le grand âge en structurant la grande
variable structurantes alors encore une
fois moi je trouve que bourdieu parle de
l'âge en fait donc c'est un petit peu
réducteur moi j'aimerais franchement
parfois pouvoir interroger les
auteurs de ces de ses articles pour leur
demander jusqu'où jusqu'où ils ont été
sur les sur les théories qu'est ce qui
fait qu'il dise ça parce que parfois je
suis un peu sur ma faim sur le détail
des articles scientifiques
alors après bon voilà après on est dans
un dans une niche ici en train de faire
ce qu'on ce qu'on fait
voilà déjà les articles scientifiques
sont très peu lu il faut le savoir
peut-être plus en sciences sociales je
sais pas j'avais donné de chiffres une
fois dans une vidéo mais je mange les
plus en tête le pourcentage de personnes
qui lisent un article scientifique et
c'est vrai aussi dans le milieu dans le
microcosme scientifique 1 dans le champ
scientifique je parle pas du champ de la
société en général
et donc ici que fait
notre auteur il propose dans cet article
de discuter cette remise en cause de
l'homologie structurale en nous appuyant
sur des données de première main donc
des données toutes fraîches qui n'ont
pas encore été de travail est issu et
brutes issues d'une enquête réalisée
auprès d'une population de jeunes pour
la très grande majorité d'étudiants âgés
de 18 à 20 ans soit une corde socialiser
en un même état de l'offre actuelle
culturel ça c'est très intéressant parce
que tu vas comment dire gelé une
variable tu vas vraiment la bloquer
s'est-elle fait de l'âge ils sont tous
du même âge donc tu vas avoir vraiment
s'il ya des différences sociales ou pas
qu'on pourra pas dire oui mais l âge qui
jouent bas non là il n'ya pas l'âge qui
jouent ils sont tous dans le dans le
même bassin est ce qu'on appelle une
cohorte
et donc des données de première main
basse et c'est l'auteur qui va générer
ces données l'humain donc c'est
particulièrement intéressant donc c'est
ce que je dis ici ils neutralisent
finalement cette variable générationnel
alors si je peux donner mon avis sur l'
influence de la variable générationnel
c'est clair qu'il ya un effet de l'âge
sur les goûts sur les consommations
culturelles parce que ce que je dis
souvent élèves tout l'enjeu de la
jeunesse c'est de faire tomber ceux qui
sont là avant eux quoi hein c'est de
remettre en question l'autorité de ceux
qui sont leurs avants donc tu vas
toujours avoir une recombinaison
par rapport à la jeunesse de certaines
choses bombay par exemple voilà
l'adoption de certains styles musicaux
de mon temps c'était peut-être que le
hard rock et puis voilà maintenant
aujourd'hui c'est le rap et les parents
n'ont pas les codes du rap ou en termes
de réseaux sociaux belle tu vois les
parents sont sur facebook donc les
jeunes vont trouver un nouveau réseau
social instagram et puis après les plus
jeunes qui arrivent trouve qu'à
instagram voilà il faut un petit peu
fait retomber est ce qu'ils sont là
avant ou en tout cas remettre en cause
l'hégémonie pour se différencier
justement générationnel m'en parle a
aidé aux petites toques émergent et donc
il ya toujours une recombinaison comme
ça avec des emprunts d'airé usage de ce
que s'il faisait avant avec des
nouveautés totalement nouvelle donc il
ya un effet évidemment un générationnel
mais après il ya autant de jeunes qu'il
ya deux catégories sociales ça n'empêche
pas qu'après il y ait des variations en
termes de
d'origine sociale
et ça je sais ce que je dis aux élèves
c'est pour ça que je vous le dis ce que
je dis aux élèves quand ils disent oui
monsieur c'est plutôt sait plus trop les
origines de l'origine sociale qui
conditionne c'est plutôt l'âge c'est ce
qui est dit ici dans l'arctique malartic
va dans le même sens que que ce que je
viens de vous dire quoi
et donc ici c'est intéressant parce
qu'ils vont reprendre l'article d'hervé
glevarec et de philippe cibois de 2018
et ses deux auteurs nous disent que en
fait une telle méthodologie comme celle
qui a été utilisée par bourdieu
fonctionne comme une règle académique
qui produit le réel plutôt qu'elle ne
restituent le restitue nos qu'ils disent
ici il accuse bourdieu et tout ce qu'on
fait les travaux au postérieur de
souvent utilisé une méthodologie qui en
fait créer des artefacts un artefact
c'est quelque chose qui n'aurait pas
existé sans le chercheur et donc c'est
une accusation assez forte et ils disent
que les goûts culturels ne sont pas et
n'était sans doute déjà pas alors la
voilà dans les années 70 qui remettent
en cause vraiment l'acte et rue de bruay
c'est quand même une accusation assez
virulente structuré en première instance
par du volume du capital donc le fait
comme je voulais dit d'avoir beaucoup de
capitaux quel qu'il soit et en seconde
instance par
ce que bourdieu appelle la structure de
capital donc le fait d'avoir plus de
capital économique ou de capitale
culturelle mais par le niveau de diplôme
d'une part et par l'âge d'autre part
quoi
alors voilà c'est très intéressant alors
malheureusement je pense pas que je vais
être en mesure de vraiment vous
restituer la profondeur du débat parce
que je me suis pas suffisamment
intéressés mais je vais vous donner les
éléments de base de ça mais voyez c'est
quand même ici on est en pleine guerre
sociologique alors justement je suis en
train de lire comme je voulais dit
microcosme de pierre bourdieu qui
s'intéresse au concept de chant un bourg
dieu nous dit qu'en fait l'habitude
c'est les capitaux ça va jouer de
manière totalement différente en
fonction du milieu dans lequel tu
évolues quand je dis milieu c'est pas le
milieu social jeudi milieu c'est à
l'école ou dans le monde de l'entreprise
ou dans le monde politique où dans le
monde religieux ou dans le monde de
l'art c'est ce que bourdieu appelle
deschamps est ici en fait on pouvait
faire une méta analyse de ce qu'ils sont
en train de faire mais bien sûr on ne la
fera pas parce que on n'a ni le temps ni
les compétences
ben finalement ici tu as une des guerres
qui est en plein en plein champs
scientifiques ont en tout cas en plein
champ des sciences sociales pour qui va
être hégémonique qui va prendre le
leadership en terme de
domination des idées de domination des
modèles théoriques est ce que ce sont
les pros bourdieu ou les antilles
bourdieu quelque part si tu veux donc
c'est très très intéressant comme
article
voilà ici je vous passe les détails
alors il me semble pourtant plus juste
d'affirmer que l'ag pour pierre bourdieu
une variable à la fois positionnelle et
contextuelle et c'est exactement ce que
je disais là je te positionnes mais
aussi dépend un peu du contexte et tu va
évoluer c'est très dynamique le motel le
modèle de bourdieu et donc en fait quand
tu arrives tu n'as pas la même position
quand tu es jeune que quand tu es vieux
quand tu va vieillir bourdieu qu'on
conçoit bien que tu t'en bourgeoise mais
c'est dire dans la distinction noir sur
blanc justement occupé à préparer une
vidéo sur l'habitude des classes
dominantes où il le dit voilà les
nouveaux entrants qui sont récents dans
dans les classes dominantes vont avoir
beaucoup de difficultés et il distingue
évidemment les jeunes qui sont nés dans
le milieu des jeunes qui arrivent parce
que voilà ils ont fait des études et
qu'ils arrivent dans dans les classes
dominantes quoi donc moi je suis assez
d'accord avec l'auteur de cet article
qui dit qu'en fait bourdieu ont parlé
que c'est un petit peu il le dit pas
comme ça met de la mauvaise foi un
cerclage renvoi l'ancienneté dans la
classe et aussi aux conflits entre
générations comme par exemple ceux
opposant la nouvelle et l'ancienne
bourgeoisie cela étant ces conflits
positionnelle entre générations c'est
incarne de manière rationnelle dans des
styles de vie et d'égout qui ne sont pas
un historique est figé
voilà aujourd'hui le conçois bien qui a
une évolution et que les choses sont
dynamiques et que les jeunes
d'aujourd'hui ne vont pas faire la même
chose que les jeunes d'hier ça c'est sûr
lorsque l'auteur analyse les goûts et
les modes de vie de la nouvelle
bourgeoisie par opposition à ceux de la
bourgeoisie traditionnelle
il décrit dans les mêmes temps les
transformations contemporaines de son
époque est tout à fait et tout à fait
moi j'ai d'ailleurs un mal de chien
résumé ça pour que ça soit parlant à des
gens d'aujourd'hui mais bourdieu en
parle voilà alors une fois il y avait
une vidéo de bourdieu où il disait ah
mais je veux bien être contredit mais on
ne contredit jamais sûr sur la matière
on compte relie toujours sur des
procédés en faisant des procès
d'intention des attaques ad hominem mais
je veux bien le croire parce que en fait
je m'intéresse aussi aux critiques qui
sont faites c'est un truc qui
m'intéresse par rapport à bourdieu et sa
théorie et je n'ai jamais trop trouvé de
critiques convaincante et finalement je
me dis ben en fait bourdieu il le disait
sa fin il répondait à cette critique là
dedans ces travaux même donc ici tu vas
voir
bon la critique qui est adressée est
assez intéressante j'ai envie de dire
mais ici voilà l'auteur m'a assez bien
convaincu sur la réponse qu'il donne
finalement et on en parlera tout à
l'heure évidemment
n'hésitez pas dans le chat à poser vos
questions
si vous en avez je vois qu'on ait deux
en ligne
et s'il est certain que la jeunesse
ouvrière à la jeunesse bourgeoise ont
été toutes deux exposés aux nouveaux
produits culturels importés des états
unis dans les années 1970 elles n'en
n'ont pour autant pas développé une
consommation toujours identique voilà
c'est ça tu vas pas avoir parce que tu
as une influence de la culture
américaine ou des produits culturels
américains c'est pas pour ça que tu vas
voir les ouvriers ou les enfants
d'ouvriers qui vont consommer exactement
la même chose que les cadres supérieurs
quoi donc ça c'est des trucs voilà je
vais pas me répéter 20 x 1 qui ont été
dits
nous proposons dans la suite de cet
article de tester la validité en pays de
cette hypothèse d'un éloignement des
jeunes générations des oeuvres
cinématographiques plus les plus
légitimes parce que voilà si la théorie
de bourdieu dit juste quand les jeunes
vont au cinéma abc tu viens de d'un
milieu aisé ce qui va se passer c'est
que tu vas aller voir des films
d'auteurs des films pointue des films
qui ont peut-être été remarqué par la
critique est situé issus des classes
populaires tu vas aller voir des grosses
blockbuster ou des grosses comédies ou
des films à sensations mais voilà qui
sont plutôt démoli par les critiques
cinématographiques c'est ça que ça veut
dire quoi donc ça va être assez sans moi
j'aime bien j'aime bien cet article
parce que il pour moi il est limpide eu
quoi c'est pas de la théorie voilà où on
commence sortir dans un an ici
l'hypothèse on la comprend bien et elle
est facile alors je dis bien facile hein
facile à dire ça surtout mais elle est
facile à vérifier dans le sens où elle
est limpide mais ça c c'est tout le
travail de l'auteur un qui a fait un
travail d'écriture qui rend son son
on travaille son oeuvre devrais-je dire
lisible et facilement compréhensibles
pour nous béotien
alors s'accordent donc les jeunes
auxquels enfin qu'ils bossent observés
sont nés entre nantes 8 et 2000 il y en
à 1351 c'est un bon échantillon ce pas
gros échantillons non plus hein faut
savoir que quand on fait des sondages on
est à 1000 1500 ans et plus une grosse
enquête de science sociale ça va être
cinq mille 5000 personnes c'est déjà un
gros échantillons mais tu vas voir ils
vont parler après on va dire que c'est
pas ça l'essentiel est donc une
population socialiser à un même état de
l'offre cinématographique c'est
important si tu avais pris des vieux un
début des plus vieux et des jeunes bon
ben voilà peut-être que les plus vieux
il regarde pas les mêmes choses tandis
qu'ici voilà ils sont dans des
conditions d'âge qui font que on peut
comparer parce qu'on a des pommes des
pubs et donc qu'ils sont interrogés dans
un laps de temps resserré ce qui est
aussi important parce que si tu tarde
trop à les interroger si tu interroges
sur deux ans ce qui va se passer c'est
qu'il y aura des nouveaux films que les
premiers n'auront pas donné et que les
suivants donneront déjà donc tu vas
biaisé un peu ton observation est donc
ici c'est observer entre avril et
septembre 2018
c'est ce qu'on a dit on neutralise la
variable de l'ag on va vraiment voir
s'il ya une différence de consommation
par rapport à des oeuvres qui sont
légitimes culturellement j'espère que tu
as bien compris ce qu'était une l'oeuvre
légitime culturellement alors voilà par
rapport à l'échantillon l'objectif de la
recherche n'est pas de construire un
échantillon représentatif
de cette classe d'âge mais de comparer
les goûts des différents publics de
jeunes aux origines sociales diversifié
ne veux pas savoir le but de la
recherche tu veux c'est pas de savoir
quels sont les goûts des jeunes on s'en
fout donc on s'en fou d'avoir un nombre
d'échantillons qui est parfaitement
représentatif
ici le but c'est pas de dire voilà les
18 20 en deux qui sont nés en 2002
l'entraînement tu t'es 2000m ce genre de
film c'est pas ça qu'on veut savoir nous
ce qu'on veut savoir dans cette
recherche c'est si les gosses de riches
alors je le dis je le dis de manière
caricaturale mais comme ça tout le monde
comprend bien si les gold les gosses de
riches on voit des films différents de
ceux qui sont vus par les gosses de
pauvres c'est tout c'est tout ce qu'on
veut savoir après tu changerais aux
riches et gosses de pauvres par classes
aisées classes populaires mais parfois
je suis un peu percutant sadc les élèves
le savent bien parce que voilà c'est
vraiment comprendre les choses
directement comme ça même si c'est
caricatural
alors ici je vais te résumer rapidement
ce qui est dit mais en fait ils
organisent il faut savoir que si tu es
belge ben voila tu vas rien comprendre à
tous dès toutes les nomenclatures des
études supérieures en france mais en
fait lieu paix voilà ça c'est un
institut d'études politiques par exemple
c'est des classes préparatoires qui vont
me permettre de faire des grandes écoles
et donc ça c'est vraiment le top lieu
paie donc là tu vas avoir sans doute
les enfants les plus favorisés on verra
après si c'est le cas un parce que tu
peux pas le le supposé comme ça quand tu
peux pas le déduire comme ça et eux deux
ces écoles de la deuxième chance donc tu
vas voir un public plus plus précaires
l'origine sociale des enquêtés qu'elles
soient mesurés par la profession et
catégorie socioprofessionnelle du père
ou de la mère comme ici est conforme aux
équilibres observée au niveau national
donc en fait on connaît un petit peu la
répartition
socio-économique de ses différents
publics qui sont dans ces différentes
filières et donc là ça a été vérifiée tu
verras il ya le tableau 2 justement
qu'on me regarde après un questionnaire
en format papier a été administré dans
chacune de ces formations durant les
heures de cours les plus souvent lors
des travaux dirigés ou découvrons petit
effectif au format équivalent ou à
défaut lors des cours magistraux ses
modalités de passation permis d'obtenir
un taux de réponse maximale puisque
l'ensemble des étudiants présents ont
accepté ou du moins n'ont pas refusé
sans doute en raison de l'injonction de
leurs enseignants présents avec nous
lors de la passation de répondre au
questionnaire tout ça c'est assez
cocasse comme formulation ici est donc
le tableau 2 bat hull là ici bob et tu
constates en effet il ya une différence
de public
regarde ici donc tu as les écoles les
plus populaires on va dire ça comme ça
et tu vois bien que tu vas retrouver
beaucoup d'ouvriers
enfin là c'est des enfants c'est la mer
à la profession de la mer qu'on a pris
mais ils ont pris aussi la profession du
père dont beaucoup d'enfants d'ouvrières
d'employés
d'inactifs et 0,2 travailleuses
indépendantes 02 cadre du public 0 de
cadres d'entreprises héros de
professions libérales à l'opposé tu vas
avoir ici une majorité
de gens dans ces formations qui ont de
bonnes positions à l'exception des
employés qui sont quand même
relativement bien représentés mais tu
vois que les employés c'est la classe
socioprofessionnelle la plus la plus
développée quoi donc c'est normal que tu
te retrouves plus au prorata ils sont
quand même beaucoup moins quoi donc ici
tu as ce qu'on pourrait appeler une
structure en chiasme on en reparlera
souvent en caisse si tu veux s'est
inversée c'est quand tu vois c'est à
l'opposé tu as deux d'un côté les
classes populaires se représenter
l'autre côté les classes aisées donc tu
as un renversement
voilà avec tout ce qui est entre les
deux ou tu auras une gradation une
évolution comme celle-ci quoi en sachant
que voilà prête à des filières aussi qui
sont intéressantes et ce qui est aussi
intéressant c'est que tu as par exemple
des prépas littéraires et des prépas
économiques et donc en fait tu peux
aussi regarder s'il va y avoir une
différence en termes de capital de
structure de capital entre le capital
économique et le capital culturel se
l'est dit tout à l'heure le fait que tu
es plus de capitale culturelle par
rapport à du capital économique ça va
aussi
influencé les goûts et les pratiques
et tu vois qu'en prépa littéraire tu vas
voir une majorité ici de cadres
d'enfants de cadres du public une
profession intellectuelle et artistique
pour être le parler le dire crûment par
exemple des enfants profs et donc ils
vont dans des prépas littéraires ce qui
est logique par contre des cadres
d'entreprises battus à une majorité de
prépa économique donc tu vois déjà qui a
une reproduction aussi quelque peu dans
quelque sorte social ici
c'est intéressant et donc tu vois aussi
que ils vont être beaucoup
les enfants qui sont un moment qui elle
travaille dans le secteur de l'éducation
de la santé voilà sur-représentés dans
la prépa littéraire par rapport à la
prépa économique
donc ça c'est super intéressant ce petit
tableau l'un
alors afin de mesurer le volume et la
structure du capital culturalité nous
avons interrogé les enquêtés sur le
niveau de diplôme et de professions de
leurs parents comme ça tu vas voir à ce
que il ya une influence de cette
position sur leur choix à eux nous avons
ensuite interroger les enquêtés sur le
niveau de fréquentation des salles de
cinéma ainsi que sur les trois derniers
films qu'ils avaient vu au moment de
remplir le questionnaire que cela soit
au cinéma à la télévision en vidéo à la
demande en streaming ou via toute autre
modalité de réception numérique ainsi
que le nom des réalisateurs de ces films
s'ils les connaissais donc tu vois ça
c'est super intéressant parce que ici va
travailler avec des questions ouvertes
et donc on va vraiment avoir le
leur le leurs pratiques sans
billet j'ai envie de dire quoi et tu vas
voir la question avec les noms des
réalisateurs est essentielle
alors ensuite ce qui est important c'est
que ils vont aussi s'intéresser aux
films après vont faire une liste
évidemment de tous les films qui vont
être cités dans ces trois derniers films
et vous repérer ceux qui ont reçu un
label art et essai parce que ils partent
du principe que ce label ars et qui est
en fait voilà une reconnaissance
la qualité cinématographique du film
mais en fait c'est un bon indicateur
pour montrer la légitimité de ce film le
fait que ça soit un film à regarder avec
une valeur si tu veux et donc je trouve
ça c'est vraiment intéressant de
travailler comme ça et puis y aura aussi
une autre à notre label qu'ils vont
prendre en compte on le verra plus loin
je n'ai pas souligner ici
tu vois et donc ça c'est des films des
films d'auteur en quelque sorte qu'ils
sont distingués des films grand public
donc ils vont se baser là dessus pour
juger je blague ou parce que j'ai ma
bouteille depuis tantôt ils vont se
baser là dessus pour voir si l'oeuvre
est légitime ou pas et tu comprends
comment ils vont faire ben maintenant il
suffit de voir si les jeunes qui sont en
classe
de la dernière chance à l'école la
dernière chance j'ai pu le l'appellation
je connais très peu le système
français en tout cas dans l'enseignement
supérieur à bien ce qui vous regarde et
autant de films art et essai que ceux
qui sont plus haut et ceux qui sont plus
haut est ce qu'il vous regarde et autant
de films dits populaires que ceux qui
sont plus bas quoi socialement cela
entendu un spa jugement de valeur
moi je trouve ça chouette parce que je
pense toutes proportions gardées
évidemment
avec une méthodologie plus simple avec
mais c'est réalisable par des élèves de
secondaire ce type de vérification donc
ainsi vous êtes dans dans mes classes
dans les classes ou ensemble si on est
donc là son ensemble franchement
inspirez vous de ce genre de truc pour
faire des petites vérification coin vous
pouvez faire ce genre de denquête 1
alors bien sûr vous n'aurez pas 1500
personnes c'est sûr mais déjà dans une
classe de votre école et puis peut-être
dans une classe d'une autre école un
institut technique par exemple où la
formation n'est pas la même c'est super
intéressant de faire cet exercice
alors nous avons ainsi qualifié les 998
films cités par nos enquêtes selon un
type au logis suivante les films
exploité en salles et n'ayant reçu aucun
label 54% de visiter
les films qui ont reçu le label art et
essai on en a parlé voilà ça c'est
l'autre label il y en a un pour cent qui
a reçu le label recherches et
découvertes et enfin les films non
exploité en salles ses directs divisé
maintenant c'est tout vod évidemment ben
voilà c'est vraiment les films de série
b qui sont pas regardable à mon avis par
mois c'est pas le genre de film qui
m'intéresse et qui ne sortent même pas
en grande salle quoique maintenant avec
netflix il ya beaucoup de films qui sont
sortis en vod mais à l'époque
20 58 dont je dis une bêtise ne tenez
pas compte de ce que j'ai dit mais avant
voilà quand tu avais pas des comptes
avait des films qui sortait pas en salle
généralement c'était pas très valorisant
pour le film et le film n'était pas très
valorisé ni valorisables avant de tenter
de mettre en relation le niveau de
légitimité de ces oeuvres avaient le
profil logique de leurs consommateurs ne
commenceront par analyser le rapport que
ces derniers ces derniers entretiennent
à l'univers du cinéma et là aussi c'est
intéressant la fréquentation des salles
de cinéma constitue la sortie culturelle
la plus répandue au sein des différents
publics interrogés seuls louis % des
étudiants de s ne sont pas allés au
cinéma au cours de l'année écoulée alors
qu ils sont 60% ne pas avoir fréquenté
de musées ou de salle d'exposition donc
tu as quand même 92 % des jeunes qui
vont au cinoche chacun le nom de 2% donc
ça c'est un film c'est un chiffre qui
est assez impressionnant
surtout quand je me rends compte moi que
ça fait très longtemps j'ai plus été au
cinéma est donc là c'est là qu'on voit
confier 66% à ne pas s'être rendu à un
concert ou un festival et 77%
à ne pas être allés au théâtre un donc
quand on dit ça aussi on peut
relativiser comme on dit pendant le coc
vite oui mais la culture c'est super
important comme les théâtres oui sauf
que le théâtre est une pratique chez les
jeunes dont l'ensemble de la population
et la geste rappelle qui est quand même
réservé une
minorité coin
alors que ce taux n'est que de 20 %
parmi les élèves des classes
préparatoires littéraires tu vois donc
là il ya déjà une différence les
littéraires forcément un bon terrain
ces résultats confirment ainsi
l'affinité du public juvénile vis-à-vis
des salles de cinéma un résultat bien
connu de la littérature et qui ne date
pas de l'arrivée des films blockbuster
et des salles multiplexes en france des
différences significatives existe
néanmoins en terme de fréquentation
notamment entre les formations
socialement peu sélectif eu de ses
supérieurs cours à es et les formations
plus élitiste si un quart des étudiants
de classes préparatoires littéraires
vont au cinéma au moins une fois par
mois
ce n'est en revanche le cas que d'une
infime minorité des jeunes des écoles de
la deuxième chance
donc il ya déjà une différence de
pratiques culturelles à ce stade
ces enquêtes et ses enquêtes et
constitue à de nombreux égards un cas
limite décrocheurs scolaires est très
faiblement dotées en capitaux culturel
la plupart des enquêtés que nous avons
pu interroger dans le cadre d'entretiens
approfondis sont dans une situation de
grande précarité socio économique qui
les oblige à minimiser des sorties jugée
trop onéreuse d'autant plus lorsqu'il
est plus souvent l oms a élevé des
enfants en bas âge bien qu ayant le même
âge biologique que les autres enquêtes
et les jeunes de 2e de ses sont soumis à
un processus de vieillissement sociale
bien plus précoce qui explique en partie
leur plus faible fréquentation des
salles de cinéma lié au cycle de vie
celle ci se raréfient avec l'arrivée des
premiers enfants et plus largement leur
quasi absence de sorties culturelles et
donc là tu vois déjà qu'iliad il ya des
vies sociales totalement différente
alors comment tu peux dire les jeunes en
faisant des généralités comme ça alors
que tu vois qu'ici il y en a déjà qui
ont qui ont des problèmes mais pas de
jeunes d'adultes quelque part ils sont
déjà pleinement dans la vie adulte avec
de vrais problèmes j'ai envie de dire
alors cette jument d'honneur je fais un
mais ça me révolte c'est bien parce
qu'on dit je ne vois là comme si c'était
une catégorie sociale unifiée et
uniforme
le niveau de fréquentation des salles de
cinéma semble alors logiquement corrélé
au nombre de fils cité ben oui si tu
vois moins au cinéma normalement tu vas
- connaître le cinéma mais ici il
rappelle qu'il avait dit que ça pouvait
être aussi les films vus à la télé ou
sur d'autres supports
alors tu vois ici justement dans le
tableau la fréquentation des salles de
cinéma dans l'année écoulée le nombre
moyen de films de réalisateurs si tu es
et tu vois ça n'empêche pas et en plus
d'avoir cette difficulté économique qui
leur empêche d'aller au cinéma il ya
quand même un déficit de capital
culturel dans le sens où ils sont quasi
pas capables de citer des oeuvres alors
voilà après évidemment les deux sont
intimement liés mais c'est très
intéressant c'est pas qu'économique quoi
c'est pas qu'économique et tu vois
qu'ils sont ceux qui connaissent le plus
de films le nombre de films et le nombre
de réalisateurs surtout parce que voilà
ils connaissent il veut par exemple les
perdons les élèves qui sont les
étudiants qui sont à eux deux ces ils
ont eu trois films cités mais ils ne
connaissent que 0,2 réalisateur tu vois
la proportion avait vraiment beaucoup
plus énorme donc ici à une connaissance
du cinéma qui est nettement moins
poussées chez eux mais bon chez les
autres comment dire filières moins
valorisé socialement quoi
c'est intéressant déjà ce tableau mais
tu vas voir on va aller plus loin qu'on
va avoir le détail des oeuvres
voilà je continue les films les moins
citées et dont la consommation et donc
plus rare ne sont pas nécessairement les
plus reconnus par les instances de
légitimation
la validation de la thèse d'une
distinction par l'éclectisme c'est ce
qu'on avait dit plus haut dit autrement
d'une opposition socialement marquée
entre consommateurs haut niveau réunie
vor
pardon c'est un peu décousu ce que je
lis là je ne sais plus où j'en suis trop
dans le dos l'article dénote une
consommation de films très unie bord sur
les 10 films les plus vus au sein de ce
public aucun n'a reçu le label art et
essai du cnc donc ici on s'intéresse
vraiment aux films qui sont cités par
les différents interrogés et tu vois que
dans les plus populaires et bien il y en
a aucun qui a reçu un label rs et donc
c'est clair que eux ils vont consommer
certains films certains types de films
les grosses productions étasunienne
louis film sur 10 sont des grosses
productions
étasunienne des blockbusters star wars
black panther et des films spéciquement
connu à destination d'un public jeune
adolescent le label tomb raider tous les
films cités sont des productions liées
au pôle commercial dont des films
commerciaux au studio du champ de la
production cinématographique comme en
atteste notamment les très nombreuses
suites alors voilà ils vont citer
beaucoup de suite les tuche trois ans
j'ai vu qu'il était dans le dans le
tableau pratique courante visant à
accroître le rendement des licences
bénéficiant d'une forte hausse et d'un
thé à appréhender comme de véritables
marques
à l'image des productions
hollywoodiennes deux films français
présents dans le classement sont des
succès commerciaux qui ont réalisé un
grand nombre d'entrées en salles
qualifier ainsi de comédie populaire
mais qui ont reçu des critiques très
largement négatifs dans la presse à la
fois généraliste et spécialisée en
raison de leur caractère trop convenu ou
de leurs intentions marketing trop mal
dissimulée libération
qualifiant le dernier film de dany boon
de comédie i wanna be bouleversant
d'humanité destinée à réconcilier tous
les segments du marché ou en raison de
leur caractère populiste en ce qui
concerne le film d'olivier baroux les
tuche 3 dont l'obs déplore la méfiance
hargneuse des élites et le conservatisme
rampant voilà donc
les comment dire les classes où tu vas
retrouver essentiellement
des enfants issus des que ceux des
classes populaires vont regarder ce type
de films donc tu vois qui a rien de
légitime dans tout ça sont tous des
films qui sont démolis qui sont
considérés comme commerciaux ou des gros
navet voilà quoi je peux pas en dire
plus en quelque sorte à l'opposé de
l'espace social étudiant le classement
des films vus le plus vu ennuyeux paix
apparaît bien différent sur les 10 films
les plus si tu y es 7 ont reçu label art
et essai alors qu'à 9 0 pour les autres
donc tu vois là il ya vraiment une
opposition qu'on n'est pas dans le même
monde on n'est pas dans le même univers
de consommation
ainsi que bien d'autres signes de
reconnaissance délivrer par les
instances de légitimation à l'instar de
la forme de l'eau second film le plus vu
sur la période qui a reçu de nombreux
prix et nominations dont le lion d'or à
la mostra de venise et l'oscar du
meilleur film on retrouve néanmoins dans
ce classement non labellisés par la cnce
et par le cnc pardon dont deux
blockbusters américains
le film de super héros black panther de
marvel studios qu'on trouvait aussi chez
les autres le dernier épisode de la saga
star wars dont un précédent opus
apparaissait déjà dans leur quête de
2008 comme un film trans classe donc
évidemment il ya quand même des films
qui sont consommés par tout le monde
mais sur le reste à part ces deux films
ces deux exceptions le reste on va avoir
des consommations qui sont quand même
assez différente
pourrait alors être appréhendée comme la
preuve d'une consommation
cinématographique plus éclectiques plus
omnivore des étudiants en classe 10e
paix et une fille née d'une remise en
question de la thèse de logis
structurale oui parce que ces deux films
qui sont consommés par tout le monde
vont finalement dans le sens de la thèse
de peterson des omnivores des élites qui
sont plus omnivore mais pierre bourdieu
questionnant prudemment l'existence de
films omnibus qui ont pour
caractéristique de faire l'unanimité des
différentes fractions de la classe
dominante de plus ces données ne nous
renseigne pas sur les modalités
différencier de réception et
d'appropriation de ses oeuvres à main
film où va être appréhendée très fort
vers à soie lycéens très différemment
selon les publics donc tout ça veut dire
que ici l'auteur dit ok et à ces deux
films qui sont trente classes mais 2 1
on sait pas ce qu'en pensent
ceux des classes aisées qui les ont
regardés il faudrait les interroger pour
savoir un petit peu quel rapport il on a
ça c'est ce que je disais avec ma femme
tout à l'heure qui regardent des
émissions de téléréalité et qu'il les
prend certainement pas au premier degré
et qui d'ailleurs se moque un peu ou
parfois être complètement effarés par ce
qu'elle voit
donc il ya ça est de 2 bat bourdieu le
disais il ya des choses qui sont trente
classes je vais prendre un comment dire
un exemple vraiment con mais voilà de
l'oxygène tout le monde en consomment ce
n'est pas pour ça que vous n'avez tous
dans la même classe sociale ben tu vois
ce que je veux dire forcément il ya des
goûts qui sont trente classes après faut
voir comment se les approprient un ces
choses donc voilà par contre moi y'a un
truc que l'auteur de l'article ne dit
pas et qui me semble intéressant c'est
que peut-être qu'il ya une sous
déclaration des jugements des élèves de
l'iut qui par exemple ont peut-être vu
des tuche 3 mais n'ont certainement pas
envie de l'avouer parce que ce n'est pas
légitime et dès lors la on irait dans le
sens de la thèse de peterson donc moi je
suis un petit peu déçu
qu'il n'aille pas plus loin il faudrait
à mon sens vraiment doubler cette
approche quantitative ici par une
approche qualitative est allé vraiment
sur les entretiens de ces de tous ses
élèves quoi de prendre voilà par
randomisation peut-être quelques élèves
j'ai pas combien mais il faudrait en
prendre quelques uns dans chacune des
classes est allé plus loin dans
l'analyse avec du qualitatif c'est
d'ailleurs ce qu'avait fait bourdieu
bourdieu s'est pas contenté de regarder
des statistiques un souvent j'avais vu
j'ai vu un tout jeune on suit la hausse
c'est le philosophe de plateaux télé qui
disaient oui bourdieu et c'est batterie
de statistiques qui font qu'ils font
parler les statistiques en disant
n'importe quoi non mais bon dieu n'a pas
fait que des statistiques et aussi des
observations et eu aussi des rencontres
enfin voilà après il faut aussi par
exemple s'intéresser à ce bouquet à la
misère du monde où là il va y avoir dans
des récits de vie qui permettent d'aller
illustré d'aller nourrir
de manière qualitative tout ça c'est
cette théorie est ce ce concept
d'habitus et 7 homologie structurale
finalement
bonjour vers alex tu vas bien depuis la
dernière fois
j'ai passé ça fait longtemps que tu es
là j'avais pu regarder trop le chat
s'était perdu dans mon article
alors aujourd'hui c'est un article ouais
super super va ici c'est passionnant
parce qu'on parle un petit peu d'un
article qui actualise ou qu'ils testent
un petit peu la théorie de bourdieu sur
la distinction donc c'est quand même le
gros classiques des sciences sociales
moi j'ai personnellement je suis
vraiment un grand lecteur de bourdieu
donc quand il ya du bourdieu ça va
toujours quoi et toi dans tes études
c'est bourdieu c'est un truc qui est lui
qu'est ce que vous en pensez dans des
études de sociaux
ça reste toujours un incontournable où
on s'est un peu critiqué comme modèle
maintenant
alors donc je reviens sur le classement
justement et là tu vois que on y op on
va avoir de tous ces films qui sont
classés en art et essai et tu vois
directement que bon c'est quand même des
films d'une certaine qualité je pense à
tous et billboard ce que je vais vu
celui-là par exemple
et là tu as le taux de réponse dont tu
vois non plus que c'est pas non plus
tout le temps
il faudrait avoir tout classement parce
qu'ici que tu as que 3% des des
personnes qui l'ont vu il faudrait moi
j'aimerais bien avoir tout classement
c'est toujours le problème avec ce genre
d'étude c'est qu'on a jamais trop le
détail par contre quand tu vois le
classement ici bas tu vois les tuche 3
50 nuance plus clair les groupes booster
quoi du bungee black panther la chine
famille voilà quoi on voit qu'au nez sur
des consommations totalement différente
avec une gradation
ici
alors je ne sais plus où j'en étais du
coup enfin si je pense que j'étais là
on est encore et durkheim bourdieu on
n'a pas encore trop parler de lui encore
bon tu tiendras ou coutu nous tiendrons
au courant de comment
bourdieu est abordée parce que ce qui
est intéressant bon pour moi c'est une
théorie en sociologie qui est
indépassable à condition de la dépasser
évidemment mais le truc c'est que depuis
que ça a été formulée cette théorie de
l'habitus la détermination des goûts par
notre position sociale ça fait 40 ans
que c'est discuter si tu veux en
sociologie et donc c'est intéressant
parce qu'aujourd'hui on a un article 2
qui date de 2000 21 qui nous pose la
question est ce que les goûts
cinématographiques des jeunes sont
encore définis par leur position sociale
ou par leur origine sociale et donc
c'est un super intéressant parce que ça
fait écho à un article de de 2018 qui
disait qu'en fait il n'y avait plus du
tout enfin il y avait c'était plus
beaucoup plus compliqué que ça et que
c'était plutôt le diplôme et l'âge des
intervenants qui déterminait leur
consommation cinématographique
ouais c'est ça bon là c'est vraiment la
quintessence de la quintessence que tu
proposes les quatre les quatre capitaux
et l'habitus parce qu'après à tous le
concept de chant qui vient se superposer
à ça et qui est beaucoup plus complexe
c'est vrai que le modèle théorique à la
base est relativement simple mais après
c'est tout ce qui est dans le détail qui
devient très intéressant
alors enfin si ces deux films ne
bénéficie pas d'une reconnaissance
institutionnelle et non pas par exemple
reçu le label art et essai ils ne sont
pour autant pas totalement déconsidéré
par la presse la plus en lien avec le
pôle artistes ils ont ainsi pu
bénéficier d'une rapide critique dans la
revue les cahiers du cinéma donc en fait
les films qui ont été sélectionnés par
les deux blockbusters donc à savoir star
wars et black panthers si je me trompe
pas sont en quelque sorte quand même
adoubé un petit peu du bout des doigts
ou du bout des lèvres par les instances
de légitimation
artistique et culturelle c'est comme ça
que je le comprends ils s'agit là d'une
différence notable avec rapport d'autres
films grand public publicité par les
étudiants des formations populaires qui
n'ont pas reçu quant à eu aucun écho
dans cette presse là shit famille les
tuche 3 le labyrinthe etc or ces films
populaires totalement dépourvues de
légitimité
on était très peu vu ou déclaré vu par
les étudiants de l'iut le film la
ch'tite famille n'a été ainsi visionner
cinéma que par trois étudiants sur 215
l'éclectisme de ses étudiants semblent
ainsi - indistinct à toute norme de
légitimer culturel qu'éclairer quoi
voilà ça c'est intéressant
cette analyse a contrario les classement
des films les plus vus par les étudiants
des classes préparatoires littéraires
comme commercial semble relever d'une
forme d'exotisme moins éclairés ils sont
quelque part moins de bon sélectionneur
des films qui sont très bien vu par la
critique et donc qu'ils sont légitimes
l'absence de différences entre les
classes préparatoires littéraires et
commerciales en termes de consommation
cinématographique peut apparaître plus
surprenant encore eu égard à la
structure patrimoniale héritée
différente de ces deux publics la
proportion d'enfants de cadres du public
est plus forte en prépa littéraire et la
proportion d'enfants de cadres
d'entreprise est plus élevé en prépa de
commerce et donc comme je l'avais dit
tout à l'heure on s'attend à ce qu'en
prépa de commerce et plus de capitaux
économiques et qu'en prépa littéraire et
plus de capitaux culturel or ça ne joue
pas sur les choses des films alors que
va nous dire l'auteur par rapport à ça
ces deux sous populations sont présentes
en proportion équivalente donc ça c'est
dans le tableau 2
on retrouve ça tu vois prépa littéraire
après pas de commerce on retrouve
finalement un classement qui peut être
relativement je peux dire identique mais
où il y a pas forcément de grandes
différences significatives
ouais par rapport aux héritiers mais il
faut que tu lises si si les travaux de
boudu t'intéresser que tu veux prendre
l'avant study la distinction quoi alors
ça c'est pas facile à lire par rapport
aux héritiers mais franchement je pense
que c'est relativement incontournable
quoi
ouais sur les héritiers battu voyage non
il n'y a pas forcément d'évolution pas
ce que je vais te montrer j'en ai parlé
en début de stream regarde ici ce
tableau
donc tu dois t'y connaître mieux que moi
toute la structure de l'enseignement
supérieur parce que moi je me connais
très peu étant pas français bon ici tu
as les écoles de la deuxième chance 1 et
puis ici tu as les élèves dits huppés et
on va voir la différence de public par
rapport à la profession de la mer et
donc tu vois par exemple qu en école la
deuxième chance tu vas avoir
principalement des enfants de d'inactifs
des enfants d'ouvrières des enfants
d'employés alors cas inverse ennuyeux
paix en école préparatoire tu vas avoir
essentiellement des enfants de cadres du
public de cadres d'entreprise de
professions intermédiaires du public de
l'éducation donc deux enseignants des
psychologues peut-être infirmiers
infirmières des choses comme ça et
finalement là tu trouves 00 enfants
d'ouvrières quoi tu vois où en prépa
littéraire 0 enfants d'ouvrières donc on
est encore dans une reproduction dans un
héritage
assez important finalement ça n'a pas
changé
même si parfois on nous dit que ça
change qu'on met en place des choses
quand tu regarde les chiffres on y est
toujours
c'est dingue
alors où est ce qu'on était
voilà on était ici
cependant rester à la seule analyse et
trois derniers films les plus vus au
sein de chaque public ne permet pas de
tirer de véritables conclusions quant à
la perte d' influence de la structure
patrimonial sur les goûts et leur degré
d'éclectisme donc l'exotisme c'est le
côté omnivore le fait qu' on aille un
peu sur tout type de consommation
culturelle comme l'observé j duval
d'interroger les enquêtés que sur les
oeuvres et rencontré un grand succès et
susceptible d'accuser le constat de
l'éclectisme des catégories supérieures
car il a il est possible que ces films
que tout le monde voit soit pour
certains membres des catégories
supérieures des incursions assez isolé
dans la culture populaire c'est ce que
j'ai dit tantôt il faudrait s'intéresser
vraiment à leur perception le ressenti
par rapport à ces films aux conditions
dans lesquelles ils ont vu ces films
pour pouvoir en tirer finalement des
conclusions la proportion a cité au
moins un film labellisé arrêt à ses
dépens plus précisément de trois
variables donc ici pour toi vers alex
qui nous rejoint les films art et essai
c'est ceux qui sont perçus comme
légitime et donc on essaie de voir si
les classes les plus aisées vont plus
vers ces films légitime que les classes
populaires qui irait vers des films dits
illégitime c'est à dire le blockbuster
où les grosse comédie qui tâche
dépend plus précisément de trois
variables la profession des parents du
père comme de la mer leur niveau
d'études et la formation suivie par
l'étudiant
est donc ici voilà tu vois le
pourcentage de films mais tu vois qui
est réellement un effet donc le nombre
de films total de films cités tu vois
aussi que les élèves qui viennent des
formations les moins valorisés site
nettement moins de films nettement mois
mais sont nettement moins nombreux aussi
sont que 46 donc ici que 42 films mais
il n'ya que 7 % donc là c'est un ratio
donc là on peut les comparer et il sait
que certes 7% de films art et essai tu
voyais la proportion gagne plus tu vas
vers des branches
valorisé comme les prépas littéraires ou
lieu p
ici on fait le même exercice avec la
profession du père et donc le top ce
corse et les professions libérales il
faut pas oublier que dans la dans
l'espace social selon pierre bourdieu
les professions libérales c'est celle
qui sont au top parce qu'elles
maîtrisent tous types de capitaux
finalement et elles peuvent traduire
leur capital un peu comme elles veulent
c'est un petit peu les grands gagnants
dans l'espace social selon pierre
bourdieu et tu vois que ça se reproduit
encore ici et puis tu as les cadres du
public en deux et puis tu as les enfants
de cadres de l'entreprise en trois donc
on a encore cette cet héritage culturel
qui jouant les héritiers sont encore
présents ici sur le cinéma est l'objet
du cinéma est particulièrement
intéressant parce que justement c'est
une matière qui n'est pas enseignée à
l'école ne qui a pas d'effets scolaires
à proprement parler dessus parce qu'au
brésil oui en prépa littéraire c'est
parce qu'ils en parlent plus oui mais au
collège au lycée on parle pas forcément
du cinéma quoi
ouais je sais pas si on a une mobilité
interne est intergénérationnel de plus
en plus à sa dot toi tu as des
des éléments a donné par rapport à ça
parce qu'en fait
il ya une grosse démocratisation des
diplômes donc la mobilité se constate ou
et puis n'oublions pas que selon pierre
bourdieu tout est une question de
relation et donc si tout le monde un
jour prendre ton énoncés si tout le
monde a une mobilité internationale de
plus en plus ascendante avant tout le
monde
grands comment dire s'élève socialement
et donc finalement personne ne s'élève
tu vois si tout le monde se lève
personne ne s'élève c'est tout l'enjeu
des deux comment dire c'est toute la
lutte symbolique selon pierre bourdieu
c'est justement de faire en sorte que
soit on s'élève avec les autres ne
s'élève pas de trouver toujours des
mécanismes de distinction qui font que
on aura des ressources qu'on va pouvoir
valoriser dans l'espace social que les
autres ne pourront pas valorisées
voilà alors modestement
donc c'est peut-être plus que moi à ce
niveau là
on peut ainsi supposer que le caractère
sexuel a oui ça c'est super intéressant
donc ou du moins cinématographique
s'exprime beaucoup moins dans le haut de
l'espace social d'une part parce que les
oeuvres culturelles légitimes sont
beaucoup moins façonnés selon après les
préoccupations de ciblage marketing en
fonction du genre et d'autre part parce
que les membres des classes sociales
supérieures semblent moins sensibles à
une différenciant
différenciation pardon sexuée des goûts
et donc on constate aussi que les
productions qui sont consommés par les
classes et plus les plus populaires à
bien vous sont beaucoup plus stéréotypé
au point de vue des genres
et ça c'est super intéressant mais
bourdieu le disait aussi qu'il y avait
une division plus poussée des du travail
domestique en fonction du sexe chez en
fonction du genre du texte je pense que
moody's ait dans les classes populaires
donc ça c'est un truc qu'on retrouvait
aussi quoi on en revanche on enregistre
en revanche une corrélation tout à fait
significatif et de forte intensité entre
le volume de capital culturel hérité
mesurée par le niveau du diplôme de la
mer c'est ce qu'on a vu dans les
tableaux plus haut la corrélation et
vérifiez également avec celui du père
avec une intensité légèrement moins
forte et la propension à avoir vu des
films labellisés arrêt c'est donc ici a
quand même une reproduction un héritage
du capital culturel
qui permet à certains jeunes de pouvoir
choisir des oeuvres légitime tandis que
d'autres ne peuvent pas distinguer ses
oeuvres légitime du fait de leurs
carences en terme de capitaux culturel
qui n'ont pas eu la chance d'hériter
mais si l'on croise les variables c'est
bien le type de formation des étudiants
qui apparaît la plus explicatif des
goûts donc on constate en effet un cas
une pause et l'acheteur juin vers alex
on constate qu'il ya une possibilité de
comment dire
de compenser par socialisation
secondaire auprès de ton de tes études
des groupes que tu côtoies lors de tes
études supérieures notamment
pour le dire autrement les rares enfants
d'ouvriers donc il le souligner ils sont
pas nombreux donc tu vois il ya toujours
une ascendance mais il faut pas
confondre son ascendance à soi ce qui
est peut-être ton cas moi c'est mon cas
un mes parents n'ont pas du tout diplôme
universitaire mon papa et où vous et
ouvriers maman était juste employés et
donc j'étais un des premiers peut-être
le second après ma cousine à faire des
études universitaires de l'infamie mais
voilà c'est pas parce que moi j'ai
réussi à faire ça grâce à mes parents
grâce à plein de choses que tous les
enfants d'ouvriers ont cette possibilité
la cua et y arrive on appris à des
trajectoires individuelles qui
qui qui interviennent alors tu dis bref
je n'ai plus la source mais dans le
monde qui nous entoure on n'entend plus
en plus de fils d'ouvriers employés
devient pays c'est quoi pays je sais pas
c'est quoi pays
mais il faut voir moi je dis il faut
voir parce que c'est toujours des
billets qu'on peut avoir en fonction de
sa trajectoire en fonction des success
stories qu'on va nous transmettre dans
les médias tu vois ici que ça ne se
retrouve pas dans cette étude si en tout
cas quoi en professions intermédiaires
ouais
je suis pas sur moi je suis pas sûr je
suis pas sûr enfin c'est toi qui fais
les études de sociaux et donc si tu le
dis je veux bien le croire mais
voilà à voir il faudrait qu'on voit ça
en détail
pour le dire autrement les rares enfants
d'ouvriers d'employés présents dans des
formations élitiste ont des goûts
cinématographiques qui se rapproche bien
davantage de ceux de leurs camarades
bourgeois que des enfants d'ouvriers et
d'employés présents dans les formations
socialement peu sélective et la même
logique s'observe en sens inverse
concernant les enfants des classes
des professions intellectuelles
supérieures
des catégories pro et professions
intellectuelles supérieures pardon
inscrits dans les formations populaire
donc en fait il ya un effet de
nivellement si tu as un fils d'ouvrier
ou une fille d'ouvriers dans des
formations élitiste tu vas avoir des
goûts plus élitiste et inversement si
c'était un enfant issu de la classe 16e
et que tu vas suivre une formation moins
valorisés tu vas avoir des goûts plus
populaires
ouais moi j'ai toujours c'est toujours
compliqué parce que
moi j'ai l'impression
alors moi je suis un transfuge de classe
tulle et peut-être aussi tu m'envoies un
petit peu raconter ton parcours
mais quand on a un transfuge de classe
il faut faire attention de ne pas
transposer son parcours personnel ou des
amis qu'on a parce qu'on va se
rapprocher évidemment de gens qui ont le
même habitus que nous et donc on va se
rapprocher de transfuges de classe
et donc finalement on a une impression
d'avoir autour de soi plein de gens qui
se sont élevées socialement alors que
c'est simplement un effet de levier de
sélection du fait de notre entourage
voilà il peut-être que je lance comme ça
on pourrait vérifier dans un prochain
stream on pourrait vérifier ce à quoi
est-ce qu'il ya une mobilité sociale de
plus en plus forte c'est intéressant et
de chercher un article par rapport à ça
ce serait intéressant tu vois ça fait la
deuxième fois merci en tout cas ça fait
la deuxième fois que tu me donnes une
idée d'article après celui qu'on va
travailler ensemble pour le bénévolat
dans deux semaines c'est la deuxième
fois que tu me donnes une idée d'article
tu reviens quand tu veux vers alex sur
le stream
allez merci beaucoup de ton soutien et
de ton de thé échanges alors la nature
de la formation prime toutefois sur
l'origine sociale assignation salutaire
donc c'est l'effet que pierre bourdieu
avait mis en avant ce qui veut dire que
celui qui est institué ce son sommet
d'être conforme à sa définition est donc
on va adopter finalement
les gouttes du statut qu'on va qu'on va
rejoindre quand les élèves issus des
catégories socialement dominé tendent à
devenir démographiquement dominant c'est
cet effet d'assignation a toutes les
chances de ne plus fonctionner avec la
même intensité voire même de s'inverser
et donc il ya un poids démographique qui
peut jouer quoi aussi ça c'est cool on
gens qui nous le dit en 2010 ainsi bien
confirmer ces résultats en matière de
goûts cinématographiques une matière que
l'école n'enseigne pas pour rappel
l'assignation statutaire dépend avant
tout de l'origine sociale du groupe
d'étudiants numériquement dominant si
bien qu'en dernière instance seule la
formation demeure significatif mans
corrélé au fait de visionner des oeuvres
cinématographiques
légitime
voilà alors maintenant il reste
juste à regarder un petit peu ce qui
nous dit en termes de conclusion à
l'heure des plateformes de streaming de
la numérisation de la culture les goûts
culturels des jeunes générations restent
toujours structuré par des facteurs 10
positionnelle dont notamment le capital
culturel hérité donc ici l'auteur marc
vraiment de manière très très forte son
opposition à l'article de 2018 qu'on
avait abordé en début de stream et qui
dit que finalement
ce modèle de bourdieu était totalement
foireux et ici nous dit que c'est pas le
cas pour ce qui vient d'observer
l'appétence donc l'attrait des étudiants
pour des oeuvres cinématographiques
légitime c'est-à-dire ayant reçu une
certaine reconnaissance institutionnelle
par les acteurs du champ
cinématographique dépend ainsi très
fortement de la sélectivité de leur
formation et de leur origine sociale ces
résultats apparaissent ainsi en rupture
avec les conclusions des récents travaux
remettant en cause la théorie
l'homologie structurale de glevarec et
si bois c'est ce que je vous disais
quelques minutes quelques instants en
effet la différence des travaux précités
à la différence pardon des travaux
précités nous n'avons pas choisi de
mobiliser les gens cinématographique qui
apparaît selon nous de moins en moins
discriminant socialement notamment chez
les jeunes générations et donc c'est un
peu le programme après un peu le
problème de méthodologie des gens qui
ont critiqué la théorie de bourdieu
c'est de dire finalement dans l'eure
dans leur approche il demande aux jeunes
le style de film où le genre de film qui
regardaient ce que vous regardez j'ai
pas de western des films d'auteurs des
mais finalement est ce que maintenant là
il n'y a pas quelque chose qui a évolué
depuis depuis un certain temps c'est que
les genres de films ne sont plus
tellement significatif puisqu'il ya
plein de films qui justement vont jouer
sur ces sur ces styles et sur ces gens à
adopter même au sein même du même film
des genres différents et donc tout ça
finalement ça se perd un petit peu et
moi ce que j'aime bien dans l'étude ici
c'est qu'elle revient sur les films en
tant que tel on demande aux jeunes de
cités ces fameux film et puis avec ce
travail de labellisation de dire tiens
ces films à son légitime ou pas quoi et
donc là c'est assez intéressant et donc
là on a des propositions méthodologiques
qui sont totalement différentes
et c'est ça c'est ça les sciences et les
sciences sociales quoi c'est c'est
réfléchir en profondeur sur les
questions de méthodologie parce que des
méthodologies différentes sur un même
objet peu va me conduire à des résultats
différents et donc s'il ya des billets
dans une méthodologie et bien on arrive
à des résultats biaisés à des artefacts
toutefois ce dispositif dans sa quête
expérimental est à bien des égards
artisanale souffre de plusieurs limites
dont il parle là du sien et là je
j'insiste aussi c'est super important
quand on fait un travail de sciences
sociales de ne certainement pas cacher
les défauts du travail parce que toute
façon on les verra et c'est un gage de
qualité d'être en mesure de dégager des
limites au travail est souvent les
élèves de secondaire ont beaucoup de
difficultés à dégager des limites de
leur travail en pensant qu'on va leur
tomber dessus mais non c'est tout le
travail scientifique parce que ce qui
est intéressant c'est que le chercheur
qui reprendrait ou la chercheuse qui
reprendrait ce travail mais elle
pourrait partir des limites ici pour
améliorer la présente recherche et
proposer quelque chose de plus pertinent
encore d'un point de vue méthodologique
concernant la mesure des goûts
l'objectivation du niveau de légitimité
des oeuvres par une instance unique
d'évaluation pose problème donc ce
fameux label art et aéré c c'est une
fausse bonne idée peut-être c'est ce
qu'on est en train de le dire ici où
elle tend à masquer les tensions les
opposer interne au chant corrélativement
oui parce que
art et essai c'est un enjeu dans le
champ cinématographique et donc champ si
le chant c'est aussi un concept de
bourdieu et donc il se passe des luttes
de pouvoir au sein même de ces instances
qui disent tiens ça c'est un bon film
c'est un mauvais film est donc
finalement il ya peut-être des jeux
aussi de symbolique qui sont à l'oeuvre
et qu'on n'a pas relevé ici donc il
faudrait peut-être aussi trouver
d'autres indicateurs qui permettent de
dire que tient on est face à un film
légitime si tu veux
alors je pense qu'on pourrait par
exemple
à léran à la rencontre de deux
cinéphiles mais vraiment convaincu de
gens qui s'occupent de ciné club et leur
demander de citer le top 10 des films
actuels qui trouve de l'année écoulée
qui trouve les plus pertinents et là on
pourrait comparer les listes si tu veux
quoi tu vois on pourrait
trouver de nouveaux indicateurs et c'est
ça aussi tout l'enjeu d'une recherche en
sciences sociales c'est d'aller chercher
des indicateurs qui permettent qui
permettent de mesurer les variables que
tu entends mesurer parce qu'ici
qu'est-ce qu'on veut mesurer dans
l'hypothèse d'un côté la position
sociale et de l'autre côté la légitimité
des oeuvres cinématographiques qui sont
consommés et comment faire pour mesurer
cette légitimité bon ici ils ont pris le
parti pris d'aller chercher ce label art
et essai mais voilà on pourrait comme je
le dis allez interroger donc faire deux
questionnaires un pour chaque variable
si tu veux
pour définir quelles sont les oeuvres
légitime allait rencontrer des
professionnels du cinéma
indépendamment de toute lutte dans un an
dont le champ cinématographique
ça pourrait être intéressant
voilà c'est ce qu'ils demandent c'est ce
qu'ils disent ici que leur choix ici
manque sans doute de finesse ouais les
sciences sociales c'est aussi l'humilité
1 dans sa recherche on a toujours des
résultats partiels provisoires
ça peut paraître frustrant ou
du coup qu'on a futiles ou comme on
appelle ça encore 20 de faire des
sciences sociales mais moi je trouve que
c'est toute la noblesse des sciences
sociales c'est toute cette humidité qui
peut y avoir derrière ou parfois y'a pas
d'humilité mais c'est dommage qu'il y en
a pas quoi enfin bien évidemment ce
dispositif visant à mesurer la
légitimité des goûts et difficilement
transposable à d'autres espaces
culturels notamment musicales et là il
fait appel finalement à un côté
important des sciences c'est le fait
qu'on puisse se reproduire et qu'on
puisse transposé en tout cas pour les
sciences sociales c'est pas tellement la
reproduction mais c'est plutôt la
transposition de voir si les modèles
sont pertinents dans d'autres contextes
à d'autres moments si tu veux et donc là
c'est un peu dommage parce qu'on sait
pas reprendre son dispositif ici tel
qu'il l'a fait sa méthodologie et aller
dans d'autres productions dont deux
types de consommation artistiques ou
culturelles pour voir comment ça se
passe si ça se passe de la même manière
voilà c'est ce qu'ils disent c'est un
peu ses limites
et voilà bon c'était quand même un super
article moi ça m'a beaucoup plu de de
lire ça avec vous alors je rappelle qu'
un choix posés bats toi tu peux
peut-être vers alex situe encore là avec
nous nous dire ce que tu préfèrerais je
vais aller sur le sur le choix de la
semaine prochaine
et me dire toi ce que tu choisirais
comme article ça pourrait être sympa
alors je vais aller sur sociaux take
you tube up
vous voulez
le bénévolat ça c'est dans deux semaines
parce que j'avais déjà lancé le jeu m'a
dit que c'était bon pour toi dans deux
semaines le a maintenant j'ai dit le 20
août
à web on écoute on fera j'ai promis le
bénévolat c'est vrai je t'ai dit le 20
août on fera le bénévolat levante et du
coup je veux se tromper d'une semaine
bon c'est pas grave
je ferais suicide en deux semaines j'ai
changé tout de suite je crois que
le sondage n'est pas encore lancée mais
tu peux me dire quand même ce que toi tu
préfèrerais ici j'ai propos soit le
parcours et la scolarisation de trois
élèves hp
donc là on est sur une approche très
qualitative on va avoir du vécu vraiment
alors on t'aime plus politique la
pulvérisation démocratique où les
clivages façon puzzle qui a inscrit
encore un axe gauche droite en politique
est-ce qu'ils aient encore des clivages
socio économique quels sont les clivages
actuels et puis inégalités sociales
disposition usages du numérique commande
notre position sociale joue sur notre
façon d'aborder le numérique tu
choisirais quoi toi dans ce choix si et
je vais en profiter pour changer la date
j'ai quand même lancé ce qu'il est prêt
dimanche prochain où le jeu mais de
dimanche 27
je sais pas le changer comme ça quoi
c'est peut-être en dessous
non je sais pas le changer comme ça bon
je changerais quand il sera publié
ou alors plus simplement je post pose la
publication
1 donc le samedi du cndd et part donc
pas samedi sam des
19 ans tu
vois là je le mets au 21 non je peux le
mettre même le 21 10 heures voila
voila j'ai replanifier
alors moi j'aime bien la politique comme
tu le sais moi je prendrais à
pulvérisation démocratique bon les trois
sont assez sympa
et ici on a le détail
voilà les enfants hp gelé mimeo j'y
crois pas trop
parce que voilà si si t'as pas un hp
dont on entoure a juste pas toi-même hp
jeu s'est passé ça intéresse beaucoup
ici cet article revient sur les notions
dix exclusions et d'électro nisme qui
traverse la littérature dédié à la
fracture numérique de colas est vraiment
la question de la fracture numérique
donc on part on parle encore en fait
d'un petit peu de la consommation
culturelle qu'on reste un petit peu dans
dans la thématique abordée aujourd'hui
et la pulvérisation démocratique est une
révolution anthropologique elle est
marquée par l'atomisation des acteurs et
l'impossibilité d'organiser des débats
d'idées argumenté de construire
libération collective donc là c'est
comment l'individualisme bien fracturé
le débat politique
est ce qu'il dit aussi je pense que dans
cet article on parle aussi de tu vois
comment dire bah tu vois un gars comme
macron il n'avait pas forcément deux
parties donc c'est un petit peu parce
qu'il ya cette pulvérisation
démocratique cette atomisation que des
acteurs individuels peuvent émerger dans
le débat politique et qu'il faut plus
forcément avoir un parti
ouais ok je garde tes idées 1
je vais te nommé sélectionneur des
articles parce que tu me donne beaucoup
d'idées c'est super
la déscolarisation j'ai un petit peu
parler quoi non mais c'est pas
d'ailleurs sur ce puits est sur ce
stream lac on s'était rencontrés que tu
étais venu pour la première fois
avec leurs 2 le pseudo de requin
sur 700 c'était ça ça valait bien plus
ça m'avait bien plu aussi on avait eu un
super stream et avait laurent et
collègues allemands qui étaient là je
fais super sympa quoi c'est quoi la
triple contrainte
c'est un article dont je le tape et
donc tu me dis ou plongée bouge le micro
la socialisation
c'est ça en tout cas c'est ça
aussi d'une socialisation enfantine sont
multiples contraintes
ça peut être intéressant ça c'est des
thèmes que j'ai pas trop aborder encore
c'est intéressant c'est intéressant
aussi moi je te remercie encore une fois
super
ben écoute moi ici je
je vais le sauvegarder
moi c'est ça hop
je vais mettre dans mon autre navigateur
ou jeu des listes de lecture ça on
pourra en parler une fois aussi ça peut
être intéressant des outils qu'on peut
mettre en place pour avoir une curation
de l'information parce que parfois on
trouve beaucoup d'articles tu as dû
avoir déjà ça aussi avec eux
comment dire à tous tes travaux que tu
as celui dont tu avais parlé
comment vous travaillez d'ailleurs avec
votre travail de groupe
comment dire
tu sais vous avez un document partagé
style googledocs ou un truc comme ça ou
vous avez un autre outil où vous
travaillez comment pour un petit peu
centraliser vos recherches ou tous
individuellement quand tu
es mais je retiens l'auteur mathias 1000
et je les mets ici dans mon dans mes
listes de lecture
ouais super et en plus c'est intéressant
parce que bon comme on essaie quand même
de donner des articles
de retransmettre des articles récents
quoi c'est sympa ça
google drive ouais
classique quoi classique mais je pense
que c'est super important
tout cet aspect de curation
bon ben voilà
22h38 cbs et bien ça on a fait un bon
stream ici
super je pense qu'on a été bien dans le
détail de l'article je te remercie
encore une fois vers alex pour ton ta
participation et on se retrouve
prochaine - dans un prochain stream et
je remercie tous ceux et toutes celles
qui sont passées ou qu'ils regarderont
cette vidéo en replay 1 à la fois sur
twitch pendant 60 jours si je ne me
trompe pas et aussi sur youtube puisque
je vais transmettre vraiment le tout la
vidéo sur youtube comme ça vous pourrez
tout revoir pour ceux qui ne pouvaient
être prêt à être présent au second
celles qui ne pouvait pas être présent
aujourd'hui à léa plus salut salut
et bonne semaine
[Musique]